time is running out to see a rare winter
phenomenon at Yosemite National Park
it's known as the fire fall and happens
right at sunset the light gives a
waterfall on El Capitan a stunning
orange glow Marco Morgan is lucky enough
to have traveled out to Yosemite in
California Sierra Nevada mountains to
see it DeMarco good morning good morning
millions of people visit Yosemite
National Park each year just to take in
its natural beauty but one of the most
breathtaking spots is the fire fall you
can only see it between mid and late
February but the conditions they have to
be just right yosemite famous horsetail
falls looks more like a lava flow this
week created a rare natural phenomenon
known as the fire fall and to see a
special part of this creation that only
takes place in a certain just a small
window of time each year makes for
excitement that's thank you photographer
Doug Hulk has been so captivated he's
come here for the past four years to
document its beauty so there's this
great feeling of camaraderie with with
people from other places and then when
that moment happens the place is silent
and you don't hear anything except just
the clicking of those shutters it's
pretty exciting
he's one of hundreds each night who make
this annual pilgrimage to Yosemite many
of whom braved the frigid weather and
fill their social media feeds with the
fire site how would you compare this
year's event to years pass every year
varies this is nature in its glory you
got to be here and see whatever nature
gives us for the fire fall to occur
nature needs to cooperate in three
critical ways the Sun has to align with
El Capitan in just the right way the sky
needs to be clear and there needs to be
enough snowmelt for the waterfall to
flow this year the icy winter has had an
impact on the view there's a lot of ice
up there so in when it's warmer you're
gonna see more water coming down over
horse tell fall part of what makes this
site so special is how brief it is the
phenomenon only lasts about five to ten
minutes right as the Sun set still
that's long enough to make a lasting
impression I think one of the most
exciting experiences
ever had in this in this particular spot
is when the light finally showed and
only showed the very top of the fallen
and the forest erupted with people
applauding and chat and cheering
whistling you know it was a happy place
to be Park Rangers say the sunset
occurrence will likely be visible for
another week so you still have time to
see it but it all depends on the weather
and speaking of weather if you plan on
coming up here you might want to dress
for it because there's a mile long hike
just to get to this point but trust me
it is worth it back to you well we can
tell you are ready DeMarco Morgan you
have dressed appropriately you are ready
mrs. Morgan would you head out yes she
would be proud Oh your mom yes you're
right nor his mom would be proud I'm one
of our most loyal viewers and we like
that piece Thank You DeMarco